all right I think we are alive on the
YouTube holy cow we did it people
regardless of anything that I say the
next hour so we did it the last year and
a half of abject lunacy all culminated
in this we all watched it we tweeted it
we Facebook did snapchatted it whatever
the hell else you do and we all survived
well I haven't heard anything about
deaths that have occurred during the
debate yet but I'm sure there were a
couple of debate related deaths probably
some alcohol overdoses but I would
guarantee that nobody died of an
overdose of lead which is something that
I wish they would have talked about
anyway there was a lot of the
interesting stuff there so I hope that
you guys were playing along on Twitter
which was where I was doing most of my
interaction but we're gonna jump over
here to YouTube now so first off you can
comment in the section right down below
and I have my crack staff of David Mira
and Emma dog here and they'll be sending
me some of your questions and comments
on the old I got a computer I got iPad I
got iPhone here she's got a computer
he's got a computer dogs got a computer
or on so let me know your questions and
thoughts I want to hear what everybody
thinks I'll share some of my stuff and
we'll go back and forth and we'll talk
about what happened for the record for
any of you right now that in the
background like I have CNN or MSNBC or
Fox whatever just mute them now whatever
you're gonna get on them is just
prepackaged nonsense there is so little
insight into what actually goes on and
the truth of what you actually saw
you're gonna get virtually nothing I'm
not saying I'm so much better than all
of those people that are on there but
what I am saying is that we have no
filter between us and I really I have no
political agenda other than I want
honest debate in this country and I want
real answers and I'm sick of the
[ __ ] that you guys are sick of and
and that's what it's about to me so
anyway so they're gonna they're gonna
send me some questions and and we'll go
for theirs but first let me just give
you my general thoughts so I think the
first 45 minutes I think Trump really
owned it I think he hit her on broad
themes about government and ineptitude
and
the stunts and the economy and stuff
like that that really is his is his
wheelhouse and and he was calm er he was
biting an attacking which first of all I
just wanna say something about the
attacking thing and interruptions in
general and I mean this whether she was
interrupting him or in earth although
mostly it was trumped interrupting her
you know we're so used to robotic
politicians and we mocked that all the
time they don't act like humans they do
talking points bah-bah-bah we finally
had a little bit of an exchange there
was actual exchange and dialogue that
was cross crossing each other they were
crossing the streams and yes are there
moments of rudeness yeah but that's what
a debate actually is supposed to be so I
thought for the first 45 minutes there
was actually a healthy debate especially
for what we're used to getting that was
a healthy debate there that was great
you know watch old debates Google what
the what the lincoln-douglas debates
were about you know we should have you
shouldn't be afraid we can't on one hand
you can't be like oh positives are all
robotic and speaking talking with and
then the second that there's an exchange
that there is passion and that there's
calling each other's [ __ ] out you
can't get oh baby this isn't
presidential that that's just nonsense I
would much rather have people be real
than presidential I'm not my president
at presidential but you need you need
some actual human exchange that's what
the mainstream media doesn't give us
that's what the politicians don't give
us so and we had human interaction and
human emotion I saw all of Twitter all
of the pundit class was all about oh
they were so rude and it's so wrong it's
so but and it's like shut up people want
human normal emotion that you and I so I
thought for the first 45 minutes he did
well then she really she's nailing him
on the taxes and some business stuff and
he got and the birther stuff
particularly he got really blathering
and offensive I think in terms of
demeanor look it is what it is so it
depends what you like so if you like
general sort of standard politician
whatever then Hillary stands there and
she smiles and she looks like a robot
and whatever in it but it seems
presidential whatever that might be he
makes more faces and he fiddles around
more Baba I think there's actual value
and that but at the same time I fully
understand why some people don't think
that's presidential but I thought he
controlled it for the most
lost a little bit at the end and then
alright so I'll let you guys throw me
out some some questions and then I'll
share more stuff also what do you guys
what were you drinking tonight
what were you smoking how did you get
through this thing I started with with
some Coronas I've shifted to wine but we
had a massive spread of all kinds of
food here but it was interesting so
alright here we go so I'm going to just
Maratha up some questions for ya
hey Dave you think the debate made a
difference for either candidate thank
you anyway even though I don't agree
with a lot of what you say - Val yor
well thank you and that's what I tried
to bring here that's okay I am thinking
I don't agree with myself all the time
that's really okay do I think it was I
think my takeaway would be that if one
of them won this it was a little bit
more of a win for Trump because he
showed that on the prime stage on one on
one he could do it and especially for
that first half where he made a lot of
points I don't think people ultimately
are voting on tax records or history
history of businesses or things like
that so the on the gut feeling thing for
the people that questioned his
temperament I think she pretty much did
the job in the first half and then sort
of lost out a second Hillary you didn't
get anything new but if you like that
then then great then then you probably
fell she she won okay let's see somebody
said well Hillary asked for fact checker
is hurt her oh so she's several times
asked for fact checkers will that hurt
her will he plays into the narrative
that she's somehow in it with with the
press right with the media cuz it's like
he said something that she was bad
checkers you feel like a schoolteacher
you fact checkers you get on that what
you get on that because you know you're
all in my pocket so I don't know that
that I don't know that it directly hurts
her but I would like to see some
fact-checking you know this thing about
Trump in the Iraq war now on one hand I
think it's largely irrelevant because he
was a private citizen at the time so
whether he did go on Stern and say
basically he was for it but if he had a
lot of private conversations now it's
hard to believe what Sean Hannity would
say cause Sean Hannity obviously is in
the tank for Trump so I don't know that
we could call sean hannity tonight i'd
say what did
say to you back in 2003 or whatever so
that's it that's a real issue but the
point is he was a private citizen she
voted for the war and by the way Barack
Obama blasted the hell out and basically
won the nomination because he was more
anti Iraq war then she was eight years
ago
so her decisions either in Iraq or Libya
or whatever absolutely led to have led
to the deaths of a lot of people that's
whether you're for these things are not
a lot of people have died because of
these decisions right uh that being said
Saddam Hussein was doing a hell of a lot
of bad [ __ ] and had great grooms and all
kinds of gassing Kurds and doing
terrible things so a lot of people were
dying either way so I'm not even making
it about the decision but the idea that
somehow a private citizens choice who
was only privy to a certain amount of
information and a public you know
Secretary of State or senators choice at
the same is a little disingenuous I
think somebody's a date how do you think
the moderator did Lester Holt so you
guys know my policy on on interviewing
my policy is that I try to let my auntie
my guests speak and if they're saying
something that's kind of crazy or out
they were saying that I don't agree with
my policies I'll let them slowly hang
themselves if you let people talk to you
so to see where their logic goes and
slowly they'll kind of Dilek to
themselves until they're they're hanging
by their own code so I think he did a
pretty good job of that I think I think
you know dealing with Trump for sure
Trump jumps in and talks over people so
it's not an easy thing everyone wants
everyone to be perfect everyone's need
to be the perfect interviewer and the
perfect moderator and the perfect
whatever it's just not that easy I say
this as someone that does this stuff for
a living but I think he basically did a
good job and he basically kept them on
point I'm curious what you guys think do
you think that the split screen was a
little distracting I watched it on CNN
and they had a split screen the entire
time I think most of the channels did
have that and I found it a little
distracting because you're listening to
one but you're watching the reactions of
the other and you really want to focus
on what they're saying you know so I'm
curious what you guys think about that
let's see hey David how do you think the
debate would have been with Johnson in
it look you guys know my feelings about
Garry Johnson I was hoping that he would
be a
to be so we could have one voice that
was different one small government voice
in this thing because neither one of
these people are small government people
but as I said in my video that was I
when I endorsed him to get him to the
debate I didn't say I was voting for him
I said I wanted to help him get 15%
saleable I tried I think I tried harder
than Garry Johnson in a lot of respects
so what do I think what happened he
wouldn't have done well because he's not
a particularly good speaker he's not a
particularly clean or or clear
independent libertarian so I don't think
he and he'd look he would have been out
policy by Hillary and out insulted by
truck so he wouldn't have dumped
particular well however I just would
have liked to have seen some libertarian
ideas even though as I say he's not a
greatest libertarian I would have liked
to seen some libertarian ideas get get
across okay somebody said what were
Trump strongest points what were
Hillary's strong these points I think
Hillary nailed him on let's see I'm
sorry to him because I think he was
better in the first half so Trump
strongest points in general I think he
makes an extremely competent argument
and a real argument when he says you
know you can go on your site and see all
your plans and you know see all the
things you would do it's like you've
been in power all this time you were a
first lady or a senator you were a
Secretary of State so why did all these
bad things happen if you suddenly
magically know the tricks he's like you
could write it on your site but it
doesn't mean you're doing it I think
that's an extremely fair critique and
it's act and I think he really that was
where his wheelhouse was at the
beginning I think she really nailed him
on on some of the taxes stuff some of
the stuff with his with his businesses
you know with the with the lawsuits with
black people I'll do a little more
research on that it's a little unclear
what he's saying is that he got out of
the lawsuits without ever without ever
saying that he was guilty or that his
company was guilty of these practices
you know and a couple times you know she
attacks his business stuff about you
know you use tax breaks for this or
didn't pay taxes on that that's what a
businessman does but for any of you that
are in business for yourself don't even
forget if you're in business for
yourself
any of you any of us have a talent do
you try to paid more taxes than you have
to if there's a loophole
do you try to use it I'm not saying do
illegal things I don't do illegal things
with my taxes but when I sit down with
my accountant I show him what I did and
we try to figure out what are the things
that are that are within the legal
limits to do and he did that as a
businessman so that's not a bit that's
it's a slippery slope when you make that
when you make that argument I think ok
let's see yeah a couple people asking
about the the split-screen thing I guess
maybe just didn't have to be the whole
time you know making it make it a little
more dynamic by not having and I thought
it was a little a little distracting um
let's see
so this is interesting so somebody said
what do you think about Hillary
attacking Trump for saying
african-american communities need to be
approved you see this as hyper critical
or hypocritical to what the Democrats
usually is fast so there's there's
interesting debate on this look a lot of
the cities where this stuff is happening
excuse me have Democratic mayor's and
have been ruled by Democrats for a long
time I think Trump said a hundred years
in some cases I'm not sure if that's
exactly true but a lot of these cities
right now that have this stuff happening
much like Chicago have Democratic mayor
so who are you blaming
are you blaming the Democrats that are
in charge or the Republicans dinesh
d'souza who I had on laid out a lot of
this stuff I don't know how much of it
it's all fully legit but I would welcome
you to watch that that interview that we
did I don't I don't think that he my gut
feeling is that he's not in in the sense
that he views people by color and says
that I would like to treat these people
this way and these people this way these
people this way I think he like most
good people would like the inner cities
to be better I don't think he thinks
that the Democratic policies are the
best for that and I'm sure she doesn't
think the Republican policies are the
best friend let's see hey Dave how do
you think Trump's answers an attitude
compared to the previous debates he
seemed really well-spoken and plight I
think particularly the first half
especially the opening he was extremely
calm and and and thoughtful I thought
and then for the first time really owned
it and then if he got
rapidly Oh think about my temper I'm the
best with the temporary you know he
speaks in hyperbole and it's a lot of
over-the-top stuff the thing is the
people that love him are gonna love that
and the people that don't like him are
gonna hate it and that's what this
election so this election and most
elections come down to it but those
people in the middle that how do you
sway them how do you sway that every
person that might agree with some
republican principles or maybe doesn't
like the person that Trump is or is that
might believe in some democratic
principles but doesn't like the person
that Hillary and that's why this is
interesting that is why this is
interesting election okay let's see hey
what was your feelings on Trump saying
he approves of the use of the no-fly
list so this is this is a slippery
argument because people don't want to
take the full argument in one point not
here so you don't know why the
mainstream media sucks right now I have
CNN regular on the phone Patti Solis
Doyle former Clinton press secretary
former Clinton presidential campaign
manager do you think you're gonna give
any truth out of Miss Patti Solis Doyle
who do you think Miss Patti Solis Doyle
thinks won the debate guess what you're
hearing pure drivel right now can we
let's just here I'm gonna put on Fox for
a second what's going on that's the
event Patti Solis Doyle
I'm sure she's giving you great insight
and honest appraisal of what happened
now on Fox let's see on Fox no somehow I
turned it I turned to him NBC me a Tom
Brokaw like Tom no problem Tom Brokaw my
remote doesn't seem to be wait here we
go Fox News has what's-her-name that
holds that woman's name someone help me
come on my team here at the blonde on
Fox all the time not Megan Kelly not
Megan became the girl that she sits
woman about 50 she sits in for O'Reilly
all the time she's got a crush to be
cross yeah somebody nobody's giving this
to me all right the point is she's a big
trump supporter laura ingraham thank you
thank you thank you whoever said that
the point is all right so you have
CNN right now CNN has a former campaign
person for Clinton analyzed pretty sure
they're gonna say Clinton won now you
have Laura Ingraham who we know wants
Trump to win I'm pretty sure she's gonna
say Trump did better and then let's go
to MSNBC which I'm not exactly sure what
channel it is think it's this
they have John Podesta who I believe is
on that yeah he's a Clinton campaign
chairman so if you want to know what the
bull [ __ ] is if there's one segment but
you want to chop of what we just did
that's it these these are [ __ ]
artists and they're in it with the media
the media is in it with them Chris
Matthews interviewing the camp Clinton
campaign spokesman right now how is that
analysis how is that further in the
dialogue how is that giving me any bit
of tongue what you should have right now
are honest decent people who either
don't have their minds made up or if
they do who can really explain to you
why they came up with their position but
not people who are campaign Chairman's
campaign spokesman's people that used to
work in administrations with these
people's husbands and daughters and
brothers it's [ __ ]
most question what was question again
Dave what would you rather see Clinton's
emails or Trump's taxes huh I think my
answer would be Clinton's emails because
if these 33,000 emails exist and if
there is some damaging stuff in there a
if she became president they could use
that against her whoever had these
emails but be she's in a position of
power and those are a public record and
either by her ineptitude or by willful
ignorance whatever you want to call it
those emails are now out there so
someone's got those emails WikiLeaks has
those emails and if they drop them the
day before the election of the day after
the election could be a huge deal either
way so Trump's taxes I do think he
should release his taxes I think he's
bullshitting of course on this audit
thing and I'm sure he has not given to
charities the way he said he's given I'm
sure he's done some shady things I doubt
he's done illegal things because if he's
not illegal you know that the feds would
be all over it
so I don't think he is I don't think
he's that he's evading you know federal
tax evasion there's that but he doesn't
want the money you see neither cuz he
doesn't
as much today as he says he has a bit of
a bit of a bragger or or that he hasn't
given as much as he said he is given but
I think that in and of itself which one
is worse the person in power that was
doing something that the FBI director
wasn't in the special prosecutor call me
said was basically he was like you're an
idiot
that's worse to me than what a private
person does with their taxes okay let's
see somebody says hate to break easy
Dave most people are gonna have some
biases of course absolutely
I have biases right everyone everyone on
earth has biases for sure but the point
is that immediately for campaign event
for debate ends and then there the cable
news where you're supposed to get news
and analysis do you think right now on
MSNBC I have John Podesta staring at his
big head do you think anyone is getting
any insight honest insight from John
Podesta who is being paid by Clinton the
answer is no and I'll change the channel
back to CNN right now if I can get over
there and and what what are they on CNN
right now but here's Van Jones who
absolutely is in the tank for Clinton
and right now Roger stone the the white
haired guy whatever his name is forget
his name at the moment for for for Trump
and then you've got Gloria Borger who
has never said a sensible thing in all
her years she's always got sources
everywhere she never names anything the
end of days David Axelrod who used to
run Obama's campaign I mean it's like
these are these are people who are all
sat on the system and nobody's accepting
this [ __ ] anymore you guys have seen
through the [ __ ] why should I
what you're I'm a freaking youtuber
sitting on an ikea couch i shouldn't be
bringing you more truth then than these
[ __ ] people yes what do you got
Geoffrey Lord is the guy that this is an
issue okay thank you for pointing that
so Geoffrey Lord is gone say no to that
so the front page of Huffington Post
right now okay it says Orange Crush
Donald destroying it debate okay
that's the Huffington Post Arianna
Huffington runs a media organization or
I guess she just stepped down that
doesn't like Trump so then that's their
analysis now go to can you go to Drudge
the birther question destroyed it yeah
the birth the question was pretty bad
but of course the Huffington Post is not
a is not a honest media organization
they're uh they're a liberal I would say
in many cases far left media
organization Drudge on the front has a
Drudge fold who won the presidential
debate and I'm gonna guess that when you
click it it's gonna show Trump hugely
because obviously it's mostly turned
Trump people go in there let's click it
and view results all right it's gonna
take a second to load but but do you see
the Bulls the media bull [ __ ] they are
spewing [ __ ] at you don't accept it
anymore don't accept it anyway that's
why there are people online that
actually seems quite ridiculous that
people have to come to me to get some
sense actus I'm doing the best I can
here but I really have one guy in couch
I was in it for the money I'd be on a
much better couch I assure you I've had
this [ __ ] couch for too long um all
right let's see somebody said we'll get
the answer to the drug thing in just a
sec Drudge might be crashing right now
but do you see that [ __ ] don't
pretend that Huffington Post these
places are just went there just websites
that are owned by rich people with an
agenda and don't pretend that they're
giving you news because they're not good
the key question why would Trump not
bring up the Clinton Foundation when she
brought up his company I don't know I
think maybe it slipped his mind and I
think he he did stammer and Yammer a bit
in the middle of that so I think maybe
he just lost his train of thought try to
imagine these people are 69 I think I
think Hillary's 69 and Trump is 70 try
to imagine them having to be on the top
of their mental game for this law for
this period of time now I was a
suspicion that they're both probably
drugged on something to be paying
attention all the time and be sharp all
the time and to know a fact Hillary was
looking down at I don't have a problem
with that
yes Siena just the same old 18 people
who predicted everything wrong
last year did you predict more garbage
alright let's see I'm gonna go to MSNBC
what's going on they still got Podesta
now you got Rachel Matt Matt Oh
obviously is a huge Clinton supporter
although she probably really like Bernie
but yeah there and won't go to Fox real
quick just to keep the the train going
to tell you that about being biased here
what do we got on Fox
we got megyn kelly and she's got Howard
Kurtz and that other guy Howard Kurtz is
I think pretty nonpartisan so that's it
that's a decent thing okay let's see
what else
seriously thank you so much for having
the balls to think for yourself yeah you
know what I don't think I'm doing
anything that great in that regard I
think most of you have the balls to
think for yourselves and I think they
dumbed us down to the point that people
think that if you say something they
think that's slightly unpopular to you
lose your job or you lose your friends
or your family we need to get out of
this nonsense
this is [ __ ] this political correct
machine that has made us all afraid to
say things why should you be afraid to
Erin whoever you support politically or
whatever view you have on abortion or on
foreign policy or something that you're
gonna lose your job or you're gonna lose
friends don't lose friends over politics
I've lost a bunch of friends in the last
year not by my doing I've had people
just die your your big analysis some
other [ __ ]
and I found better friends by the way
guess what if somebody's gonna somebody
unlike your politics and they say I'm
not your friend anymore
I just lost a friend this week that I
thought I was friends in Boston this
week if someone is like because your
politics then go find better friends
there's better people out there than
these than these fearful these fearful
people let's see
somebody said debate since when is
regurgitating talking points pulled
together by a staff of hundreds of
debate they both they both lost big time
look there's there's certain construct
what our system can allow everything
being equal we should have
lincoln-douglas style debates which is
just the two of em for like two hours
plowing through each other time after
time and yet I would argue for almost no
rules and let them interrupt let them
speak over let them be
it would be a more raw and real thing it
would be more honest than what we have
that said this was pretty good try to
just keep in mind what debates on what
you've watched in the last year the
Republican and Democratic debates this
was a pretty solid in terms of an actual
back and forth an actual attacking of
someone's record Trump was all over a
record you voted for Iraq you voted for
Libya you know some of these other these
other things what you're going to do
with with the economy and you've been in
power for these last eight years and all
that and she attacked him for for his
taxes and so his business dealings all
that that's that's a pretty solid debate
all things considered and considering
how mangled our media and our politics
aren't I thought that was pretty solid
hey David you think that as Hillary
suggested Trump has ulterior motives in
pushing his tax plans especially in
regards to his business or personal
business partner slow I can't I don't
know what's in his heart but Hillary has
a ton of friends when Hillary talks
about the giving away of money or you
know maybe you didn't give this much to
charities I think the Clinton Foundation
what is it that they even wait 9% of
their donations
there are hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars in donations have
actually gone towards the causes right
it all goes to operating expenses which
is basically just keeping rich people
rich and making other rich people feel
good that they're having 50 not $50,000
meal dinners with the Clintons and other
people in power so I think there's some
interesting things like when she says
well you just want tax breaks for the
rich you know it reminds me of like
something like the estate tax argument
so the estate tax for those of you that
don't know is that the government comes
in there's a law right now and the
changes every year or every few years
but right now there's the estate tax the
federal estate tax needs have them as
well and the federal estate taxes around
5.3 million dollars that means if you
die and you have over 5.3 million
dollars that the state the federal
government basically can come in and
take about half of it that the state can
just take it that that money was taxed
throughout your entire life it's your
money to give to whoever you want and
the state can just come in and do it now
some Democrats and people on the left
say well that's fair now give that money
to poor people to put that money in
other things I would argue and by the
way I don't have 5.3 million dollars
more Santa to inherit 5.3 million
dollars I would argue what right does
the state have to take money that was
already taxed tax it again before giving
it to the people that you want to give
it to you it's your money
so it's an ethical argument I think that
being said we have to figure out a
better taxes I mean I keep when they'll
say well the wealthy people aren't
paying their fair share I mean wealthy
people pay a huge percentage of their
taxes a huge percentage of the tax
income that comes do we need a fairer
tax system that makes more sense when
people can't cheat and people can't hide
money in the Cayman Islands and all of
this other [ __ ] absolutely but there is
difference between what an argument that
sounds good and easy and an argument
that's real so like you know like the
minimum wage for example and we've
talked about this on the show lunch you
know you can just say Ernie kept
screaming about $15 minimum wage and
then Hillary and then the young people
go crazy for that that sounds really
great
and who didn't who tried to she said
well I do 12 and maybe we'll get it to
15 and people are like you a freakin
sellout arguing for minimum wage hike
trumps against it the thing is with the
fit with the minimum wage hike is it's
hard to tell a private business how they
should run their business so if you said
to McDonald's all right you're enough to
give all your employees $15 an hour
guess what
they're gonna replace half of their
staff with iPads so instead of talking
to somebody not that that's really
pleasant experience about you're gonna
just punch things in on an iPad and then
instead of 50 jobs at McDonald's where
they hire people you're gonna have ten
iPads that they'll have bought once and
a guy that comes in once month to fix
the iPads and somebody in the Queen's
the grease off so these arguments need
to be made and honestly mature ways not
simple not simple in idiotic ways and
unfortunately we're not particularly
good then Dave what do you think about
them letting the audience react to the
responses isn't the moderator supposed
to shut that down I absolutely think
they should be allowed to respond we are
humans with human emotions why should
you not yell out to cheer and something
you like or something dog the audience
by the end I decided to do whatever the
hell they want it which was great
good Lester quiet shush shush them I
guess
by the way if he attrition that would
have helped Trump because it would been
it would have been thought of as I seen
the media trying to show the Trump
people although Hillary got some
applause breaks and a couple apps on
that but I think that's nonsense that's
absolute nonsense and if you want to
know what nonsense it is you're in fact
check me on this but four years ago when
Newt Gingrich was running for the
Republican nomination
there was a run where he had like four
debates in a row he just crushed
everybody he was by far the best debater
and partly what he was doing was using
the crowd and he was getting people to
cheer and boo and scream and then
suddenly I don't know where they just
announced though sorry crowds you can't
do that anymore so the pump because the
party wanted more on admit Romney more
they wanted you King Grich so the
inherent flaw in all this is that the
parties do whatever fun thing won the
debate Commission that sets this thing
up they're the ones that picked the
arbitrary number 15 percent to stop Gary
Johnson will get it in and Jill Stein so
the system the system protects itself
and these guys are kind of these guys
are kind of getting on it together
that's just kind of how it is do you
think that the performance from Hillary
will put an end to the doubts about her
health I think the people that doubt her
health are gonna continue to doubt her
health there's no doubt about that
they'll keep mocking it and I think he
means about it talking about it I think
what we saw that day on September 11th
in New York City was was legitimately
scary my initial reaction before I
jumped on Twitter when I first saw it
was scary that was a lifeless body that
was a fully lifeless body that was just
crumbled and carried into a bag that's
scary
so I don't think it'll click into those
questions ah and on CNN right now they
have John Messina who is Hillary's
campaign PR guy I'm sorry that's box
right now and let's see what they've got
over on CNN I'm guessing more glory or
your our there actually they've got
somebody talking to Trump all right
that's pretty good on the floor and
let's see what's over at MSNBC they've
got Andrea Mitchell doing a little
analysis okay Andrea Mitchell I'm 99%
sure she's voting for Clinton but I
think she's a basically decent woman if
she's probably trying to give some
somewhat moderate analysis so there you
go usually dressed exactly like Hillary
Clinton which is a little bizarre all
right where are we
Dave how do you think Johnson would have
fared in this debate against both
candidates not particularly well
unfortunately I mean the I said this
earlier I don't think the guy's a
particularly good debater
I don't think it was particularly good
handle on the issues I think he's a
babbler and a little silly I like him
personally I liked him on my show I
talked to him for a half hour in the
greenroom privately and I really liked
him I thought he was a decent guy and
I'd love to go hang out with them and
because skiing with him it's one spot
but I think he would have been
overridden by Trump's attacks and I
think Hillary would just policy the [ __ ]
out of him and I don't think he would
have done particularly well that being
said I think it would have been good for
America to have seen another choice up
there there is nothing as I've said
repeatedly in the last couple weeks
there is nothing in our Constitution
which is the laws that were governed by
there is nothing in our Constitution
that says where are we supposed to have
two parties we have a two-party system
because the two parties have tricked us
into thinking that's how it's supposed
to work but that isn't how it's supposed
to work and that's why we get the
gridlock that you get you know that's
for just a sec we got about fifty five
hundred people out here which is great
if any of you are on the Twitter you're
on the other social media things tweet
out to people that were here bring other
people here you're here bring some other
people out here yes thumbs up from the
team okay all right so easin what would
you have asked that you were moderator
you know I would have done you know I
like doing a little bit more of the
broad stuff and I think maybe I would
have opened with something sort of
simple but like that might have just put
them in a different frame of mind what
happened was why do you think that you
are uniquely positioned to lead the
world and do you think that it's
possible that that makes you a little
crazy because I don't know that they
really get asked either one of those two
things maybe the first one a little bit
but I think and them do you think that
makes you a little crazy to be to put
yourself under this scrutiny and have
this amount of power to have the power
of God the ability to kill millions with
the press of a button and all this stuff
like
I would have liked some personal
philosophical understanding of why they
think what they think that's the way I
conduct music but maybe we'll get that
maybe we'll get to that in the next word
let's see
Trump is kept it together for half the
debate then allowed it to unravel
significantly you think Trump performing
similarly in automatic scenarios would
be damaging to American relations so I
agree with that analysis which is what I
said I think the first half he was on
point then he unraveled a bit I think
that's possible
but you know when you're in negotiations
with these people I think well you know
what I was going to do something that
was gonna be completely conjecture there
so I don't know I think that
negotiations are tough and we have to
suspect that because of his business
experience that he's basically a good a
good negotiator so I don't know that we
could judge that either way
and here's Hillary walking down with her
fake smile great let's see hey BAE my
live streaming debate here in Australia
how do you think the results of the
election will affect us here overseas
well first off hello Australia and I had
read up not beyond from the herald-sun
over at Australia she was on and just
taped it she'll be on next weekend we
talked a lot about Australia because one
of the things that I say often doubt is
that you know we don't talk all we talk
about now is the election year we never
talk about foreign policy we never talk
about any other country simply my bomb
goes off so we talked a lot about
Australia so I hope I hope you'll dig it
and as I said she's on this week sorry
let's try to read it or not he is on
this week so how do I think this stuff
will affect you overseas look clinton
has somewhat of a track record of some
military ventures she was for she was
for libya I suspect she's been for
bombing in Syria you can find my
feelings on all of those things when
I've done public videos what they most
of those things were happening I was
against all of them but by the way that
doesn't make me morally superior because
Saddam Hussein was doing horrible things
as I said earlier in this video too but
I was completely against Libya and I was
against Syria at least without a
coalition let's I kept saying let some
of the other countries do it from
and Trump what I think he's gonna do
look this idea of having the countries
that are in NATO a US for our defense
I mean Japan's a pretty rich country and
we we pay our military defends them so
is is it odd to have them pay us I mean
I don't know everything about
international relations but I know
something about it doesn't strike me as
if if we're doing something for you you
do something for us
so it's hard to say how any of this
stuff would go but I think it would be a
different set of rules all together with
Trump whether that would be good or bad
remains to be seen hey babe honest
question
have you become any more tinfoil since
escaping progressivism have I become
more tinfoil meeting more are you saying
more meeting that I'm wearing the
tinfoil hat so I am conspiratorial not
exactly sure what the question is but I
have escaped progressivism I think
progressives basically have gone off
that the deep end and they've ruined
huge swath of the left
I'd say the left in America 80% of it is
are things that I don't stand for in
there against free speech and therefore
censorship and therefore demonization
and they use all that coded language of
racist bigotry of whatever to stifle
debate and therefore all this [ __ ]
on college campuses with trigger
warnings and safe spaces and all this
nonsense and and they're not tolerant
they tell you I'm taller n't they are
and that they tell you how not racist
they are and they talk about race and
Creed and religion all the time I think
progressives have done a really terrible
job with true liberalism and I think a
true liberal or classical liberal has
more in common with a libertarian and
actually it used to be then then they
would with someone out the far left or
on the far right you know two great
examples of this are the ones that I
used which are you know gay gay rights
and marijuana you may not care about
either one of those things but as a
liberal you could say well I'm for gay
rights because I see a gay person over
there and I want them to look back just
like they can live and I and I like
smoking weed I'm liberal with weed it
comes to when it comes to weed I like
smoking and a libertarian might say you
know what I don't care about that gay
person but I don't want the government
telling them but they can't enter
so I'm okay with gay marriage and I'm
the libertarian I don't think we should
about wheat or I love wheat or whatever
but I don't want the government telling
me what I could smoke in the privacy of
my own home so that those are two simple
examples where libertarians and
classical liberals real liberals can
come together very easily so that's
where we have to do some bridge building
and the progressives are not for bridge
building they're for burning bridges and
demonizing everyone that doesn't agree
with them and the second day change you
know the second progressives are okay
with gay marriage if you're not okay
with it you're a homophobe that's just
stupid
eight years ago Barack Obama ran for
president and I say to you is not
forgetting marriage right so was he a
homophobe at the time no politicians are
fearful of made they leave last often
even Obama and but progress is second
something happened the second a trans
issue pops if you don't change the
second the way they change now your your
transport it's nonsense it's not it's
not the way humans of Oliver humans
think it's not good for for discourse in
any way how do you think the debate will
affect the polls I'm gonna guess that
there's gonna be a little bump for Trump
it sounds like the polls have been
securing his way a little bit so far I'm
gonna guess a little little bumper truck
I I think that the polls are basically
gonna stay closed this entire time and
no one's gonna know till that night
let's Cirie Hillary pointing out Trump
getting money from his father are you
responsible for what your parents did
and did not do Chelsea has lots of money
from Hillary could she be considered the
same camp as young topless absolutely is
a terrible line of argument by Hillary
and I think it's disingenuous and
dishonest Chelsea Clinton why do you
know who Chelsea Clinton is guess what
her dad was the President of the United
States
her mom was the senator from New York
who became senator because her husband
was the President of the United States
and then after that he could became
Secretary of State because she was a
senator because she was the first lady
so that's the only reason we know the
Chelsea Clinton is and by the way
Chelsea Clinton is gonna end up running
for something probably senator and this
is we left we left England because we
didn't want monarchies and we're
building them here right we could have
had a Bush Clinton thing we've already
had two Bush presidencies so I think
it's a horrible argument if your parents
your ancestors your forefathers your
grandparents
they worked hard and they set you up on
success and then you took that success
and built on it why should that be held
against you this is such a this is such
a God forbid you regressing this is a
truly regressive view of things you
should be proud of success now you can
argue that maybe the business dealings
teams done haven't been good or honest
or you did shady things or hasn't paid
some taxes maybe should all of that
stuff but the argument that you should
be punished for this for the supposed
sins of your parents because they were
well-off and they hope you develop what
garbage that is doing he's going oh my
father was a coal miner oh ah that's
great
he was a coal miner you then moved up
the ladder pretty you did pretty good on
that ladder thing and guess what Chelsea
has been given everything and gone to
every private school and been handed
everything in her life and guess what
she's probably done a lot of good in the
world and with charities knows what else
so holding that against the Trump kids
is is absolute [ __ ] Dave do you
think at this point in the election do
you think Bernie might have fared better
than Hillary against Trump I don't know
because I think the system right now you
know Hillary represents the system Trump
represents the outsider and had it been
Trump and Bernie you would have two
Outsiders attacking the systems from
different places Trump from a more
capitalist place Bernie to more
socialist place I don't know that the
system would allow that actually pretty
sure the system wouldn't allow it
because Democrats basically fixed it so
that Hillary was gonna be Bernie no
matter what so you know I don't know
that Bernie would have done any better
or worse you know I think I like Bernie
the man better than I liked a lot of his
policies I think he's a decent guy but I
don't buy into a lot of his policies and
I grew to like him less as the campaign
we're not but you know maybe do you
think the political dynasties and
massive inherited wealth are a threat to
democracy usually hugely what do we have
right now we have a former president's
wife it's former first lady running
against the million you don't need much
more than that
you don't need much more info than that
to know that we have a problem here why
if you were a good decent person
let's say me for example I study
politics I have a decent analytical mind
I like this stuff I care about this
three very much I like having hard
conversations all that stuff I would
never run for pricing I would never
present why would I want everyone
ciphering through every email that I've
ever said every voicemail that I've ever
left our system is so horrific that
we've created a system where the only
people who will ever run are the people
that have been in it forever or people
who are so rich that they can they can
figure out ways to silence I'm going
beneath it's a major flaw in the system
and I hope no matter what happens after
this that this is the last election that
we're going to have like that of course
I hope that we're gonna have the third
or fourth or even a fifth party hey Dave
long time fan how do you think a trump
presidency would change US American
relations and Europe greetings from
Austria how do I think it would change I
think that a little bit wait we need to
wait and see how Greg's it works out
because there was a real different
dynamic there now in the European Union
I don't think it would change it that
much that's the irony
I don't think Trump would actually
change that much but I do think he would
change our negotiating posture on some
things may not work maybe will work yes
would our would he talk to people in
different ways that were used to talk
yeah you would but I don't know that it
would change alter the relationship that
much I think I think Europe's in a lot
of trouble right now and that's why the
Reds have both happened and people are
really upset about what they see
happening with borders and the economics
and an immigration and all that and you
know it's one of these issues where if
the Left won't deal with immigration
honestly and every time you want an
honest discussion about it they tell you
either dig it then what's gonna happen
the right is gonna come in and take over
so this is where this is why I talk
about the left on time you guys don't
understand why I talk about the left is
because I want the left to be better
because if we don't talk about things
honestly at liberal and clearly using
logic we just hand everything to the
right and and I personally would prefer
that in that what strategy should both
candidates changer adopts for the next
debate Hillary in my opinion just still
needs to come off more human and I know
that's not why you should vote for
somebody or not vote for somebody Barack
Obama came off as very
president oh but you know the her fake
smiles her every movement seems like
it's been prepared for the last 40 years
people are people are over that sort of
posturing so I think she needs to come
off as more human less Sun you know less
scripted I think would be good for and
Trump I think has to still figure out
how to and he did a really good job of
it first half of controlling his emotion
and making good point by the way he
seemed to have a much bigger command of
issues that he has had which I thought
was kind of impressive actually maybe
that was his big reveal tonight I I had
to knock out these losers little Marco
and lyin Ted you know stupid whoever but
then you know that he he needs to take
that take what he built on that floor at
first 45 minutes and now expanded on it
not and not seem like he's rampaging
through her and he has have clearer
answers for something stuff you know
what if you're saying well I'll release
you know I'm not only Singh the tax
records because of the audit and at the
same time he said but if Hillary
releases the 30,000 pages of emails all
released attackers how about beater the
punch like be the better person in this
case say you know what I thought about
what I was going to do it anyway there's
nothing tonight so I'll do it and now
the onus is then on Hillary and the
media might turn on so I think that's
the way you could you could play it a
little bit yeah hey Dave what was your
opinion the most intellectually
dishonest of the debate I gotta think
about that for a second you guys let me
know what you think well I'm thinking
for a second intellectually dishonest
moment I need to I need to think it
through more I don't have something
that's jumping at me at the time it you
know the thing is we're so used to being
lied to all the time and be force-fed
act truths but at some point they start
saying things like there were a couple
moments where we were all sitting here
and we were like is that true is that
not true you know there was the line
about Hillary saying that the deaths in
New York City have gone down under de
Blasio where they were talking about
stop and frisk which no longer exists
under Mayor
and and Hillary Trump keeps saying
that's not true that's not true that's
not true
now I lived in New York City when it was
shitty shitty before Rudy Giuliani and
or ever bad I couldn't remember my
great-grandma I lived in New York City
and I remember going there when I was a
kid I'm talking about in that early
eighties and go there and he was
disgusting and you would never go to
Times Square and it was a disaster and
then that and some of that was on Mayor
Ed Koch that David Dinkins it was really
a nightmare out there him both Democrats
and then who cleaned it up he was Rudy
Giuliani and Giuliani was using stop and
frisk on now it may not be
constitutional I'm a little confused
whether its constitutional or one judge
struck down the use of it I don't know
if that necessarily makes it
unconstitutional I couldn't I could be
wrong on that so we can we can look into
that but Giuliani a Republican governor
did a Republican mayor did clean up New
York City there's no doubt about it
but so for example that was a good case
where the fact-checking we needed it on
the fly she's saying deaths have gone
down under de Blasio and he's saying
they've gone up well what's the truth I
don't have the answer it from somebody
saying okay if you people are saying the
deaths have gone up since the blast
years building alright so in that case
the Hillary okay so sorry so some people
are saying that that was the distance on
the moment the deaths have gone up
things I don't know what the answer to
that is right as radula that's right the
second so we'll stay on that let's see
yeah we can we can shift away from just
policy stuff so yeah it was look it was
it was something we just watched
something it almost feels like you know
like after you have sex and then you're
like who that was that was a lot no I
think it's like cleared of your mind I
think that we America just went through
that we all just kind of fun and this is
where we're at right now and we've got
two more of these things we've had a
vice president vice presidential debate
as well and we'll see I think we I think
that was a pretty healthy debate if you
want a silver lining if you're nauseous
by all this stuff if you just
of all this that should be your silver
lining right now is that that was a
pretty solid debate there there are real
differences between these people there I
don't particularly by year one of them
I'm telling the truth and I think
they're very different people and I
don't think that the the worst things
that people say about each of them are
really true I don't think that Hillary
is necessarily being controlled by
secret globalists who want to destroy
the borders and make us a European
global nation-state and I don't think
Trump is a secret white supremacist
who's running to restore the white
nation but I do think these are people
who have really different views on how
America should be run really different
views on how capitalism should be run
really different views on how the state
should is impose its power rather in
terms of military or in terms of
whatever so so here's a good example of
sort of intellectual dishonesty when
Hillary is talking about Trump's taxes
and you know saying well he wants he
wants to save all that money on taxes he
could have gone to something else could
have gone to this or that it's like
you've been for wars that have cost a
lot more money than anything that trump
could have saved American taxes so
that's the kind of type of thing that's
just sort of nonsensical okay let's see
yeah so all right you're giving me a lot
here all right I think we're gonna wrap
this thing up with the guard for about
an hour and a half the whole debate is
only an hour nap so I give you an hour
and a half by myself unscripted off the
top of my head what oh oh Jesus does
that mean I have to do another half hour
all right I'll keep going a little bit
if you vote a little bit more this is
you know what I think I'm gonna take a
30-second commercial break as we say in
radioland a reminder that the show that
we do the Reuben report is fully fan
funded so you can go to Reuben
report.com / donate and you can donate
on PayPal for a one-time donation or you
can donate on patreon which is
patreon.com slash Reuben report and
people donate a dollar a month
$20 a month we've got people that donate
$500 but and that is our budget that
allows us to do the show we're trying to
get to a place where we will be doing
two shows a week hopefully soon and that
pays my salary and here's how
a teller will take the same salary by
the way pays for Emma's dog food and it
allows us to grow the show we built a
production company and I'm really proud
of what the community that we've built
the types of conversations that we're
having and I don't get the money that
CNN or MSNBC or Fox could throw my way
but honestly I don't think I would take
that money now because I have a direct
line to you guys and it's a kind of
beautiful thing so it's rumored apart
concise donate it to monitor jump in on
that and and it's appreciated and
helpful it gives us the budget to go
ahead and do the show we don't fly into
partnerships that we don't want to enter
and we're able to we've no filter
between between us right well there's no
filter
it's media that's it okay Dave during
the debate Hillary emphasized the notion
that words matter what ways do you think
this both hurts an alter so the words
matter thing in general I think we can
we all get caught up on words right so I
do think words matter but I I would say
there's a paraphrase of slings and
Harrison I would say intentions matter
more your intentions matter than your
words we can all get caught saying
something that we don't quite mean or
miss speaking in a certain way I know
what it's like sometimes I'm
interviewing somebody or I'm doing one
of these things and I start saying
something I'm like that's not really
what I meant to say that didn't come out
the most artful way and I'll see this
every now and again on Twitter even or
wherever someone will clip something
that I said literally for three seconds
me saying three seconds were something I
said I get in the video that I did a DM
that I did a week or two ago and I said
something to the effect that it doesn't
matter if you're right or wrong the
important thing is that you get heard
someone on Twitter click that and said
here's what do bad things it doesn't
matter if you're right or wrong and they
click the first happened it said and it
was me saying it doesn't matter if
you're right or wrong so I keep lying
that I have like moral relativism for
something and it's like that was not
like point that it doesn't matter a good
writer we should all strive to be right
whatever that is but my point is that
the important thing is that you speak
your mind because if you speak mark your
mind something to speak there hopefully
they can convince you is right you
commit them aside so words do matter but
I try not to get I try I do get caught
up at it sometimes too in the outrage of
the day you know someone said this this
way and slightly said
and it's like you know what and then and
then automatically what do we do we
label them a racist or a bigot or it's
like you know and you're allowed to
whatever your private thoughts are in
your own home you're all how to be a
bigot you are I don't like you if you're
a bigot but you're allowed to be a big
if you start legislating you start
trying to use legislative power to enact
bigoted laws laws that are against gay
people are against black people or
against Muslim people or whatever then I
have a problem with you but in your own
body you're allowed to say accidentally
stupid things or even intentions or
jokes that don't go over well and that
shouldn't be a referendum under whole
life we have to stop constantly jumping
down everybody's throats the second they
say one thing you don't like it now
everything else they've said in their
lives is off the is off the charts
let's see besides freedom of speech what
issues do you want to explore more on
the rubric work on the future so I guess
I want to do more on economics because
we've done a little bit on economics and
mostly I think from a libertarian place
but I would like to get in some some
more mainstream conservatives on that
I'd like to get some mainstream leftist
on that some socialist so I definitely
do more on economics I had a really
really cool chat today it'll be up next
week with Zoltan Istvan he's running for
president for the transhumanist party
that you've probably not heard of but
their whole party is about technology
and health and how so many things are
happening right now about AI and
designer babies and stem cell research
and futurism all of this stuff that he's
gonna have massive implications on our
lives in the future and no one's talking
about any of these things so we had a
really cool conversation that was half
sci-fi half politics which are my two
favorite things so I definitely would
love to do more on the science front
that I'd like to talk some work to some
more religious people obviously I've
talked to a lot of atheists but I'd like
to talk to more people of faith we have
a we have a bishop and a rabbi it sounds
like the beginning the joke we got to
work out an imam but yeah we're gonna
okay stop question and frisk has
decreased nearly 97 percent since in New
York City since oh here we go
trump claim okay so according to the
Trump claim New York City were
was up post stop-and-frisk and according
to this MSNBC fact-check the New York
City murder rate hit historic lows in
2016 so if that is the case then this is
MSNBC saying that if that is the case
then Trump either misspoke but it more
sounds like a direct line so that's a
nice piece of journalism right there
they've got Howard Fineman who I think
is a decent guy and he's giving them
fact-checking
they said something let's fact-checking
but not let's ask the campaign spokesman
what they thought of the person who's
paying them if you could choose one
person alive to be President who would
it be
I know Sam's not gonna be happy if I
said this but I would vote for Sam
Harris I think he's the most decent
smart thoughtful person that I that I
know personally and professionally
and I think he has a flexible flexible
mind that he's willing to to hear other
thoughts and change his mind and I think
that he's dealt with the types of
attacks relentlessly dishonest smears
that you have to go through to become
president and who wouldn't want some of
it that's that smarter philosophically
profound to be President so yeah I
assure you he won't be please don't send
that to him he doesn't want to be
President absurd I don't want to yeah no
hey Davey are you gonna make any Star
Wars references in this live stream well
I will say this you know on TMT this
week they showed you all six of the
first things they didn't show force
awakens yet and I something because I
watched them all again and I've seen
them all obviously a jillion times the
problem with the prequels beyond that
George Lucas decided to write and direct
and executive producer well so it was
just too much of a lift for one person
and he wasn't as sharp as he was back
today by the way he didn't direct Empire
needing correct for attorney general but
was a big lift for him but the story of
the prequels really is a massive
political story yeah the story is about
young Anakin becoming Darth Vader that's
right but there's really a massive
political story related to the fall of
the Republic how a leader can gain more
power and start wars
are the separatist war and start the
separatists and the look Amazonas
missions
start a war between the separatists and
the Republic that then allows him to
gain more power so there's some really
cool political stuff there it was just
such a freaking heavy lid and I think
that one day maybe they can redo them in
a way that would be better because yeah
although Revenge of the Sith I think
it's a pretty solid movie especially the
second half
you know Phantom Menace is top and
Attack of the Clones is just confusing
like who is siphon he is I know cuz like
research but I should have to research
okay do I think the Trump's answer to
the race question alienated more
african-american voters or gain more
support I think here Emma best dog on
earth I'm a 20 ema20 16 she's the best
she was rescued from Hurricane Katrina
in New Orleans
and she's lived in so she's in the New
Orleans New York City she's lived in LA
she's been to the White House has been
to the Grand Canyon seven good life do I
think his answers I think it depends on
I think with some people it's gonna help
with something that's gonna hurt how
about that I would judge people as
individuals not as a fraud community in
that way by there at MSNBC right now is
Donna Brazile donna Brazile for the past
year has been a CNN contributor she was
also a super delegate they somehow
didn't bring that up that often and ii
debbie Wasserman Schultz got canned by
the DNC they hired they hired down a
Brazil so they're all they're all
they're all in bed together alright cool
so I'm gonna I'm gonna wrap in ten
minutes so I'll give you ten more
minutes here so yeah you can throw out
some questions doesn't have to be super
said hating you're a fan of sci-fi any
good books you'd recommend as a starting
point there is a great great collection
of short stories by philip k dick philip
k dick who wrote many things like Total
Recall and Minority Report
Blade Runner and many other things you
can get a really really
collection of his stories and he wrote
what was that movie the cartoon movie
with Scanner Darkly and it's just simple
stuff so you could be you know several
short stories of a nighter
on a night for 20 nights but I do love
some good sci-fi I'm looking forward to
is it Westworld coming on HBO
yeah I'm looking forward to Westworld
which I think comes out next week
so all right all right I'll take a
couple more questions that I'm gonna
wrap it up Rubin report calm / donate
favorite episode of The Simpsons that's
a great question so the symptoms from
from episode 4 or episode 4 so in Star
Wars mode from season 4 to about season
9 that's as good comedy as there is you
know I'd say Seinfeld's probably the
best sitcom of all time the Golden Girls
is the one that I hold the closest to me
but those years of The Simpsons are
probably the greatest comedy just pure
brilliant irreverent comedy so many
great episodes in there I would say
there's a couple that I don't think I
could pick one when the when the family
moves to that town with Hank Scorpio who
homers boss who becomes an evil Lord
evil manager it's just brilliant
brilliant brilliant that's a great one
where they're also bored because or
Marge gets so bored
because then she has the houses take
cleaning itself that she has to start
drinking and she says she says Homer I'm
so bored I started drinking every day
drink two glasses but I just can't drink
that much there's a great line I think I
finally butchered it there but it's good
but trust me I would say that when I
would say the Halloween episode with
Lisa stew is one of my favorites the 3d
episode is phenomenal
the one where Homer trips on the
Guatemalan insanity peppers that might
that might be my favorite if there's a
favorite Lisa's a vegetarian episode but
who shot mr. burns are absolutely
absolutely brilliant what else there's a
lot more a good one
oh when when Milhouse becomes
radioactive man or Fall Out Boy so many
good episodes there's so many good
episodes there I did well on the market
with Homer in class and I have a line
every day so you're supposed to
two lessons I just can't drink that much
I used to be used to do that better I
haven't busted that one out in a while
Oh Bobby for their job the reinard
patreon link right now below if I'm
gonna talk about that
it's patreon.com side fifty cents
whatever it is you know yeah oh there's
a lot of people are asking for more
streams we do worry this kind of stuff
yeah we will you know I get just I like
this because I get to yes we are doing
these every month people I'm laying down
the law right now yeah oh yeah I see
what's happening here
so I got 18 screens going at once
everybody we do these every month so I'm
gonna do more of these sort of look for
the wife because we do these for the
exclusive for the patriarch people where
you I do this for like hundred people at
a time or we do some of the patreon
rewards I do Google Hangouts I think we
have a couple openings left where I do
Google Hangouts for just ten people
which is very cool because we've all
sort of gotten to know each other and
it's people all over the world that
we've gotten to know each other and then
and then we do one-on-ones as well so
okay here we go I'm gonna answer one
more question then we're gonna wrap it
up and I appreciate you guys this is
great thousands people watching us
because do you think it's worth pursuing
politics today as a career with the goal
of pushing the goals of alternative
media I think alternative media has more
work to do to set the stage for the
right political people but we need it on
two fronts right so if you're if you dig
this and you want to go into politics
you'll have allies here whether you
whether you know you'll have allies
whether the steven crowder or me or ben
shapiro or whoever it is you know like
you'll have allies that exist in the
online space that you may not agree with
and then you may agree with and then
hopefully you can if we had the right
people now that were support this and
this is why I think Eric Johnson really
missed the boat on something the media
was ignoring utterly ignoring tically
screwed up aleppo who did that stupid
thing with his tongue
and he had that horrible interview about
illegal immigration and it's like if he
had just said you know what screw the
mainstream media I'm gonna do this all
for online
and really focus you know he didn't do
my show and it got hundreds of thousands
of you but if he had said I'm gonna
focus on all the online shows I'm gonna
go to everybody I'm gonna go to Rogen I
think he did but really I mean that's my
gonna be Michael he couldn't build
something much bigger so I think you
needed on two fronts you need the online
people do the online thing and then you
need the you need the the candidates
whoever they are and hopefully hopefully
it's you out there watching right now to
go on that front and that's how well
that's how we'll change the system all
right cool it's been fun I've been
talking for a long time we did it
everybody like we got through a debate
and just remember the world is not gonna
end at the end of us even if the person
that you don't want gets in we have a
system of checks and balances the world
will go on the Donald Trump if you hate
Donald Trump he's not you know when
Hillary was going on about the nukes
it's like he's not running he has a very
good life this man he has millions and
millions if not billions of dollars and
and and a big family he's not running
for president to destroy the world and
at the same token Hillary Clinton is not
running for president to destroy the law
that doesn't mean that either one of
them might not destroy the world they
might but I but I think this is where we
should try to take their intentions a
little more a little more clearly and a
little more thoughtfully and don't lose
friends over this stuff and but have
honest discussions have hard
conversations because otherwise what's
the point you know like don't censor
yourself you know I it's supposed to the
government is supposed to come from our
free speech net that I want that but
don't cover yourself don't come for
yourself and go don't lose friends over
politics and all right that's it it's
been fun we'll do it again and I got a
thing Emma wants to go for a walk yeah